das sind meine fünf tipps für ihren
urlaub im nächsten jahr
tipp 1 ich hab immer gesagt
pauschalreisen buchen ich muss das jetzt
ein bisschen revidieren weil ich glaube
auch im nächsten jahr werden wir mit
corona zu tun haben dass irgend erstmal
keine pauschalreisen buchen erstmal kein
urlaub buchen und ich glaube auch dass
die skisaison auch in gefahr ist also
erst mal abwarten wie sich das geschehen
überhaupt entwickelt tipp 2 wenn sie
dann buchen ganz wichtig immer auf
kostenlose stornierung achten am besten
noch so dass sie noch am tag der anreise
auch tatsächlich ihre unterkunft noch
stornieren können
tipp 3 bei reiseportalen nicht unbedingt
nur noch den preis sortieren sondern
wirklich nach kostenlose stornierung
tipp 4 bei auslandsreisen wenn sie das
jetzt schon planen kalkulieren sie in
ihrem budget immer ein dass
möglicherweise auch noch
kostenpflichtige corona tests dazu
kommen das heißt also bei einer
vierköpfigen familie können da schnell
über 200 oder 300 euro sein
ganz wichtig einkalkulieren und tipp 5
minimieren sie das risiko am besten auch
vor ort noch keine festen aus flüge
buchen sondern erst mal schauen wo
reisig überhaupt hin und dann praktisch
zusätzliche angebote dazu buchen